une dentellière aux reflets chocolat et
bien maintenant les cherry on va faire
une dictée par la nasa avait interrompu
reprise ou une sortie neige est fort et
sortez tous une feuille et un stylo à
bille sur la b devant vous celui qui
peut le plus de fautes devra porter un
bonnet d'âne pendant toute l'émission
extrait de la dictée de bernard pivot
2011 en france attention aux noms c'est
chaud tu peux me dire que les chéris
c'est parti là là là ils adorent ça et
là ce sont attisées glace eux sont
atteints chez moi avons deux sortes
étaient partis dîner naturel de clocher
là ce sont attisées d'inénarrables
querelles de clochers et se sont
chamaillés jamaï deux de plus
oui chamailler pour des peccadilles
pour des peccadilles puis rabibocher
très tôt je sais que ça ira bibeau chez
puis rabibocher rabibocher qui sait que
ça là de quoi voilà la saq et même dans
les bouchons qui fait de vous êtes sûr
de sa force et on l'évité mois wacogne
rabibocher nombre de générations
non mais c'est une phrase no hero 2
générations
disons qu'en d'autres temps par d'antan
dans nos droits des générations pourquoi
on n'est pas même site vous dites vous
qu'en d'autres temps se sont retrouvés
une dentellière d'autres dites vous
qu'en d'autres temps ci sont retrouvés à
six sont à 600 au sahara saucisson s'y
sont retrouvés s'ils ont retrouvé
j'en profite pour dire aux
téléspectateurs que jusqu'après aura une
caméra cachée de greg dit oui
ah oui et non trop bien dans le
magnifique on peut avoir une vue qu'en
d'autres temps ci sont retrouvés une
dentellière dans une dentellière une
dent tenir oui aux reflets dit vous
qu'en d'autres temps ci sont retrouvés
une dentellière aux reflets chocolat
non
à l'aller nous
je mens
mais ma place
[Applaudissements]
sookie
j'ai beaucoup
ses yeux se sont posés sur moi il m'a
à
je n'ose pas lui qui compte pour moi je
[Musique]
le m